utilizing the joe with this grip isn't
really seen in aikido however in this
video i wanted to look at some options
of how to potentially be used
[Music]
in a previous video i talked about
thrust utilizing this grip with both
thumbs pointing outwards if you've not
seen that i recommend going to watch
that first now initially this grip might
feel weak vulnerable or not particularly
useful
and that's likely to do with the fact
that with both homes pointing outwards
palms are pointing inwards and
it leaves this part of the grip exposed
so if there was any potential strikes
here it could easily
just come straight out of your hand
conversely though if we were to change
our grip round and have both thumbs
pointed inwards this feels much stronger
you can create a frame so if there was
any strikes you could absorb it
much easier there are however paris that
do utilize this grip although it's
either the top or the bottom hand using
this position now at this point it's
important to know and i have mentioned
this in previous videos that ideally
from a martial perspective you really
want both homes point in the same
direction and the reason for this is
because it creates more stability and
it's easier to transition
into other movements
and to other positions
that being said we do utilize this grip
so why not potentially look at other
ideas of what could possibly work so
going back to what i was saying
if you take a look at those two parries
that i showed previously
the reason that this one works is
because the hand here isn't rolled
inwards
like i said at the beginning this
exposes the weak part of the grip it's
actually rolled outwards creating this
support through the palm and down down
the arm
likewise if i was to show you from this
side
the bottom hand here
again that's facing
outwards
rather than my palm being rolled inwards
which would make this grip quite weak
and again if there was any impact it'd
lock this straight out by hand so if we
took both those parts linked them
together we not end up with a parry
that looks something like this that can
then easily transition into the thrust
that i've talked about previously
and then into all the movements
[Music]
anyway i'll play about with this and let
me know your thoughts in the comments
below and by no means saying that this
should replace any other movements or
that should even be used it's just some
ideas that i'm experimenting with myself
i hope you all enjoyed this video and
until next time take care and i'll see